if I had Facebook my status with this
movie would be it's complicated The Lion
King so in a world of live-action
adaptations of animated Disney classics
The Lion King is a live-action
adaptation that's all CGI but I'm gonna
call it live-action from my part here
because this movie is treated like
live-action I feel like if it was
animated if it was considering itself
animated the Lions and other animals in
this movie would emote a different
emotion other than the baseline
indifference I'm gonna assume you've
seen the Lion King or know what the Lion
King is it's it's Hamlet this is the
live action yet CGI remake of the
animated remake of the live-action
Hamlet a lot of the time it's an
impressive CGI reskin of the animated
Lion King that does quite a few things
not quite as good as the animated Lion
King I'm really I looked at the hashtag
The Lion King as a bunch of people that
came out of the premiere and a lot of
them said the same two thing Timon and
Pumbaa steal the show and visually it's
remarkable those two things are
absolutely correct so correct in fact it
might actually be on the blu-ray case
because that's that's undeniable they do
go a bit overboard on the fart jokes
with Pumbaa it's like hey Pumbaa was
ghastly in the animation but this is
ready PG so we'll like quadruple down on
it funny there's a huge Lion King fan I
do have a couple problems with this
movie the biggest and most glaring is
the fact that yeah like the Lions and
the animals they don't actually show
facial emotion or expression that well
they do move the eyes and eyebrows a
couple times a little bit and then it
does help most of the time this movie
does accurately emulate Lion emotion in
the face that's a lion's happy face
that's a lion sad face that's a Lions
confused face see what I'm getting it
it's kind of hard when it was first
watching this movie when a guy to this
movie I thought the dialogue seems stiff
the characters seem stiff it's like they
don't seem emotional like if I wanted to
see a bunch of emotionless characters
I'd hang out in the dystopian future of
equilibrium but when I'm really thinking
about it it feels like it's the Lions
that feel that way like if I look at the
characters that stood out for me Zazu
Timon and Pumbaa shawnzy they actually
do a cool thing with shawnzy that brings
her into the foreground as an actual
antagonist not some side character she's
the leader of the hyenas and you feel
that in here thought that was cool I
don't know if Jon Favreau was like all
right guys we're not gonna actually have
the Lions show a lot of emotions so if
you could
not show a lot of emotion in your voice
that would help because it would help
mix it well with the facial expression
it look really weird if you sound
emotional but they don't look so
emotional so I don't know if it was a
call like that that was made I assume
something like that had to have happened
because even James Earl Jones who plays
the same character he played in the Lion
King animation even he feels a bit more
flat and it could be because I don't
have the visual facial expressions to go
with the voices so it doesn't feel like
they're as emotional because they don't
look as emotional it could be a
psychological thing like that yeah
absolutely all I know is it kind of I
feel a disconnect when I watch this move
because you know I'm a human being
I like seeing emotions in the face
that's just kind of how we are maybe not
all of us maybe you can roll with it but
I kind of can't but I also think a big
thing at work here is that the Lions
were more locked into iconic dialogue
that wasn't made for these actors like
if I'm looking at scar for example
Chiwetel Ejiofor
great actor and he's going for a darker
more brooding scar who's just fine
you're going for a different scar but
for the most part in this movie he's
delivering lines made for a more
eccentric Jeremy Irons scar doesn't
really fit well with the acting job he's
doing in here even when he has the mouse
and Zaza comes in and he loses the mouse
iron just like look so you made me lose
my lunch this is like saucer however
there's this one scene this new scene a
dialogue between him and Surabhi it's a
new scene for this movie written for
this version of scart it's actually
awesome so I'm like alright he crushed
it there so when he's doing Jeremy Irons
lines that that's where the conflict
happens I feel like that happens a lot
in here he's just like no no actors
you're doing lines made famous and made
for other actors from 1994 but it
doesn't really mix so well with the
actors now they have to be free to do
their own thing and when they do their
own thing it's actually quite good and
that's why I think zazous shawnzy Timon
and Pumbaa they all stand out to me cuz
they have the most dialogue that's new
and I feel like it was them just
ad-libbing you know I'll just do my own
thing and make it mine without losing
the essence of the character feel like
they might have had that freedom more
than the lines but the fact remains at
the core the route the dialogue of
characters the emotion in this version
of The Lion King not as good as the
animation and this movie has a problem
with this pauses and beats going to
compare it again to the animation can't
you review the remake without comparing
it to the animation no I can't in the
original Disney
Meishan Nala and Simba they scuffle when
they're adults and Nala pins him to the
ground and he goes Nala and she backs up
and there's a beat and he goes it's me
Simba and you can see her like kind of
processing it like seriously and then
you know there are beats in there where
the characters are processing
information this movie doesn't do that
just like boom Nala Simba yeah oh okay
okay
no beats you're not you just kind of
know now and it happens quite a few
times quite a few times in this movie
the Lions are coming out and it's like
they're just going through the motions
because they're like alright this is
classic dialogue we're just getting
through it and made the characters if
not the actors kind of come across this
board even with some of the
cinematography I mean there are some
extraordinary looking things that happen
in this movie absolutely not taking away
from that but there are some shots from
The Lion King animation that would have
really done well being here like that
epic sweeping oh my god was a Pride Rock
reveal not in this movie stampedes about
to happen oh my god Simba realizes he's
in deep [ __ ] shot shots not in the movie
and there's not a comparable shots like
no but there's an even better shot now I
mean the intro is otherwise a really
cool recreation of the intro to the Lion
King but now looks like live action but
yeah the reveal of Pride Rock just kind
of slides into frame it pans over and
when it comes into friend and the music
is epic is coming over a hill and there
it is and they took out be prepared and
filled it in with some half-assed
version of be prepared it's like be
prepared that whole song number isn't
really in it there's like half of a be
prepared song number but they were like
oh fans are mad be prepared it's not
gonna be in it well just half-ass a
version of it like if you're making a
remake of something and you take
something out you have to put something
back in order to make it feel even
otherwise you're just making the
experience lighter and I feel like this
remake took out more than it put back
that's just simple as I could put it the
moment they actually elevated in here is
the lion sleeps tonight moment you know
Timon and Pumbaa are going in the jungle
in the animation they're singing that
they do that in here and it's actually
they do the moment better and it
transitions to another moment in a new
way it's like it's a familiar moment
that they do in a new way that makes the
experience new and they actually elevate
good on that moment I suppose more
moments in this movie did that Hans
Zimmer score is great who's great the
first time he did it do but it's really
neat to see the arrangement and what's
the same what's different where he might
have tweaked this how this sounds a
little different how it sounds
it's fun to do I mean if you're a big
music head that might be worth watching
it just for that guys in the end this
wasn't it did feel like a it's a Disney
cash grab but I thought this movie was
actually pretty solid as a tech demo
it's like a mod you know like Final
Fantasy 7 on PC how they have user mods
where's like all right they don't look
like blocky polygons actually look like
more detailed characters there are mods
that do that this feels like a mod like
that only imagined as a result of that
mob the characters dialogue and emotions
feel a bit more flat that's the
trade-off you make for incredible
visuals you know this kind of breaks my
heart but whatever I'm just gonna say
this movie probably be a better time if
you're drunk yeah what yeah it's I'm
never gonna see it again well I have a
better version of The Lion King that has
better moments that gets to the point
better that I just I like how they did
the characters better I would ever watch
the live-action one again if the CGI is
keeping this movie afloat that's only
gonna keep it afloat for about a year
we'll see great CGI and movies to come
that aren't out yet
alright so live-action yet not quiet
live-action what doesn't matter because
after I do this video I never have to
hear about whether or not this is
live-action or animated again Lion King
remake have you seen it what do you
think about it whatever he thought
comment below let me know and if you can
give this video a like I do appreciate
it it does help the video but does help
my channel out thus help me out
certainly help my stranger things season
3 review it did not appreciate that
it'll probably help this one too and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]